MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce Andy Biggs.
Andy's actually going
to do a lot of the
introduction himself.
He's going to talk a little
bit about his work
and how he got here.
But there's a couple of
highlights that I do
want to point out.
So Andy was the winner of the
2008 BBC Wildlife Photographer
of the Year in the category
of Wild Places--
is that right?
ANDY BIGGS: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and
it's a killer image.
So that's one of the accolades
that he's got.
Andy is a Silicon
Valley veteran.
I don't know if he left or if
the Valley spit him out, but
I'm sure he'll tell you
the story of that.
But Andy is one of the premier,
one of the best
African wildlife photographers
that I've ever met.
And it's really awesome to have
him here and speak to us.
So take it away.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY BIGGS: OK, everybody
hear me OK?
All right.
So I'm Andy.
And I'm an African wildlife
photographer.
And this is now my
fourth career.
I'm 43 years old.
And yes, I'm a Silicon
Valley veteran.
We left in 2002.
But when I got out of college in
1991, I was an accountant.
And I thought that I
was great at that.
I might have been decent
at it, but I hated it.
I hated it.
So I moved into the consulting
world doing financial software
systems for a long time and
ended up in Silicon Valley,
working for Rational Software.
And in 2000, somebody said, hey,
you want to go out with
me to go take some
photographs?
We're going to head over
to the ocean over
by Pescadero Beach.
And you have a camera?
And I thought, no, I don't.
So I guess I should buy one.
So I headed up to Keeble
& Shuchat,
and I bought a camera.
And that's been a journey now
that's lasted really for the
better part of what,
13 years now?
So eventually, after working my
tail off in Silicon Valley,
I decided that it was time
to end my time here.
Because mainly we wanted
to start a family.
And it was a very difficult
environment to start a
business, a safari business, out
here with a high cost of
living and try to make it all
work and start a family.
So we moved back to where we're
from, which is Houston.
And we put everything
in storage.
And we took off for Tanzania.
And we went away for
a month and a half.
We had no plan after a week of
planning once we got there.
So we said, we're going to go
climb Kilimanjaro for a week.
And somewhere on Kilimanjaro,
we'd figure out what we're
going to do the next week.
And then at the end of that
week, we'd figure out what's
going to happen the next week,
which is very unlike my
behavior, my personality.
Because I used to
be a planner.
I was a project manager.
And so I used to plan everything
to the nuts.
And so somewhere on
Kilimanjaro, I
realized that this is--
I needed to put a business plan
together to actually turn
this into a business.
And now 11 years later, I'm
doing it full time.
I've been doing it full time
for many years now.
But it's been a blast.
So what I wanted to do today
is talk about transitioning
from Silicon Valley--
what I call Silicon Valley
to the Serengeti--
and then talk about photography,
maybe just look
at some photographic examples,
look at them, talk about them,
the approach to photography,
how I think creative
photography should be the
driving force behind people's
photographs, not what does this
button do, and how do I
make it work?
The creative side should always
drive the craft, not
the craft driving
the creative.
So I want to get into
that a little bit.
Aravind mentioned this
a minute ago.
This is the winning image
from 2008's BBC Wildlife
Photographer of the Year.
It's a photograph of the
Namibian Skeleton Coast, which
is a country just above
South Africa on the
western coast of Africa.
And we were taking a bush plane
flight one day all the
way up the coast towards
the border of Angola.
And normally, the coastal fog
sits over the water, and you
can't see it.
And this day, there was
no fog on the water.
It was all over the
sand dunes.
And these sand dunes
are basically 1,200
to 1,500 feet tall.
So they're really, really
large dunes.
And to give it a little bit of
perspective, there's actually
a seal colony down here on the
bottom part of the screen.
Give a little bit
of perspective.
So when it comes to photography,
I think the
starting point of photography
should be coming up with a
list of adjectives, as opposed
to, I've got a camera, and
this is what I think
I want to see.
And I'm just going to capture
everything in front of me.
I like to start with a list of
adjectives, like hopeful,
remote, timeless, regal,
uplifting, happy--
as opposed to aggressive, sad.
There's a lot of different
approaches to wildlife
photography, and we're going
to see those in a minute.
And I don't like to take that
approach that most other
people take.
I'm looking for more big,
wide open scenes,
things that tell a story.
Because photographers--
we are visual storytellers.
And visual storytelling
is difficult.
Because we have the assumption
that there are no words with
any photograph.
Sometimes there are.
If you're lucky, it's in a
magazine with a wonderful gold
border around the front.
But most of the time,
we don't.
Most the time, photographers
are trying to illustrate a
story with one photograph,
not a series of
photographs with no words.
So here we've got a photograph
of a giraffe underneath an
acacia tree in the Serengeti
National Park.
Just trying to get a sense of
place, what's going on.
We have all grown up knowing
what giraffes look like.
We've seen them in books.
We've seen them in
children's books.
And we know that they've
got spots.
We know they've got horns.
But we don't have to fill the
frame with it because our
memory fills in those gaps.
All we have to do
is show a shape.
And we're going to talk about
shapes a little bit with black
and white photography
a little bit later.
But I thought kind of start
off the discussion talking
about the whole adjective
approach--
find out what you're interested
in and how to
photograph that.
Because you're going to be
editing your photographs
before you even click
the shutter.
How you compose and how you tell
a story is all starting
with that, your requirements.
And the requirements are, for
me, hopeful, timeless, remote.
I don't like to have anything
that looks like it's been
man-made in my scenes.
I don't want a road or a path.
Because sometimes we
are on roads in the
middle of the Serengeti.
So when I left Silicon Valley
in 2002, I had to transition
into this world of being a
full-time photographer.
So that requires income.
And income for me comes from
running photographic safaris,
not so much being
a photographer,
licensing the images.
That does happen.
But it's really leading
photographic safaris, teaching
photography out in the bush, and
showing people how to have
an appreciation for what they're
seeing and then how to
capture them.
And here we've got two young
lionesses on the ground that
we get this eye contact with.
And I look for photographs
that have some sort of
connection to the viewer, that
somehow draws the viewer in.
And a lot of times, the eyes are
the things that are doing
that for us.
Here's another kind
of scenic image.
Here is a bull elephant, a
male bull elephant in the
Okavango Delta in Botswana.
Looking for some clouds, a
little bit of background, a
reflection, but something that
kind of places the animal in
its environment, that kind of
tells us the bigger picture,
as opposed to filling
the frame.
Not to say that I
don't do that.
I do that as well.
But I try to vary the looks of
the photographs so that people
don't get what I would call
visual fatigue, the
same-looking photograph
every time.
And the way that photographers
should and can do that is by
shooting vertical, horizontal,
zooming in, zooming out, going
in for detailed shots, going
in for big landscape shots.
Here's one of my
safari groups.
You can tell this was
a winter day.
This is in July in Botswana.
And we all have our
jackets on.
And coming from Texas in
July, it's awesome.
Because it's 105 degrees
where I am in July.
And I can get on a plane,
and it's 45.
It's fantastic.
Again, back to this visual
storytelling idea--
when shooting in black and
white, which is very different
from color, one has to really
pay attention to shapes.
Because when you remove the
color information from a
photograph, you're basically
left with nothing but shapes
and textures.
And there's a language with
color that's all removed.
So whenever we talk about
contrast in photographs, we
usually talk about--
we're thinking of black
to white, something
with a lot of contrast.
But in the color world, we have
hue contrasts, so the
difference between reds
and blues, or
maybe blues and yellows.
But we take that away, and we
have to have more to stand on.
And so what I do is I'm always
looking for clean backgrounds,
clean elements that are easy
for the human eye to figure
out what's going on.
And here we sat here, watching
this lioness on a rock.
She was asleep for
a few hours.
And we just wanted her
to wake up and yawn.
It's all we wanted
her to do, right?
So sometimes sitting around in
a Land Rover for hours is an
opportunity to read a
book, tell jokes,
take a nap, do whatever.
But patience pays off.
Patience pays off.
And in the safari world, driving
around in a vehicle
thinking that something's going
to happen right when you
pull up to it is
very misguided.
It's very misguided, because
it never ever
happens that way.
You don't drive around
and you're like, oh,
wow, look at that.
There's a lion about
to kill something.
No, you have to watch
things transpire.
And you have to pay attention to
what's going on around you.
Now, this is the opposite of
what I talked about a minute
ago, which is kind of the big
scene, the big overall
sweeping vista.
This is a photograph of a mother
elephant walking across
the road in front of
us, protecting
the rest of her family.
She just stops, looks, makes
her ears look larger.
And certain mammals are easier
to photograph than others.
Elephants, I think,
are the easiest.
And the reason why they're the
easiest is that they give a
lot of non-verbal cues.
Because how they socialize with
their other family units,
proximity, their tail movement,
how they move their
head gives you an idea of
what their mood is.
And ultimately, that's what
I'm trying to convey.
So we're back to the whole list
of adjectives, right?
If you come up with that list of
adjectives, you're going to
be looking for very specific
behavior in an animal to try
to photograph that moment.
And sometimes, storytelling is
kind of bending the truth.
Back to simple elements.
This is a photograph in South
Africa a few years ago.
We just waited for a lioness
to climb up into a tree,
because she saw a herd
of Cape buffalo.
She wanted to get a better
vantage point, figure out how
to approach them.
So she jumped up in the
tree, looked around.
And I was hoping to get a shot
where her tail was actually
still in the frame.
Because a lot of times,
photographers, we will get so
excited and zoom in and
go straight for
the eyes, the head.
And we'll totally forget about
the tail and the legs and
everything else.
So you have to have a lot of
breathing room in these
photographs.
So we've mentioned
a few images.
And we'll return to
those in a minute.
But I wanted to talk about the
life of a safari photographer.
When I started this business, I
was thinking, oh, I'm going
to take a bunch of
photographs.
It's going to be great.
I'm going to lead
some safaris.
I'll take some photographs.
And that's going to be it.
Well, the reality is that
I'm a marketing guy.
I've got to build a brand, who
I am, communicate that out to
the market.
I've got to sell safaris.
I've got to put them together.
It helps to have a cost
accounting background.
So I know how all the
international rates work with
the monetary and how to hedge.
And I have to be able
to run a trip.
I have to be a leader.
I have to be a guide.
I have to be able to say,
this is a giraffe.
Here's what it's doing.
Here's why it's doing it.
Here's how to photograph it.
I have to be a photographer.
I have to be a teacher.
I have to teach photography.
Andy, what's an f-stop?
What's shutter speed, ISO?
What's all that going on?
I don't understand
how to do that.
And I have to be an accountant
when I get back home, because
I still have to pay vendors.
I still have to keep
the business going.
And so I have to wear a
lot of different hats.
But I'm an outsource
model kind of guy.
So I outsource to these
different companies in Africa
for the camps.
I outsource to these
guys as agents.
And I have myself
in the office.
I used to have an assistant,
who used to do a lot of fun
printing for me.
But he moved up to New York.
And I haven't seen
him in a while.
But for the most part, I'm
an outsourced business.
It's really great because I have
the freedom to not really
worry about a lot of things.
And I just kind of remotely
manage other vendors.
In 2008, I licensed a bunch of
photographs to Banana Republic.
And as a wildlife photographer,
it's a very
unusual environment to be in.
So essentially, Banana
Republic being in
the clothing world--
I would call them still in the
fashion world, even though
it's not high fashion--
a wildlife photographer existing
in a fashion world is
like oil and vinegar.
We have two totally different
languages.
And when their ad agency called
me and said, hey, we'd
love to use your photographs
as the cornerstone of our
urban safari campaign.
What do you think?
I thought, yeah, it
sounds great.
But I have no idea
what you want.
So let's figure this
out together.
So what they ultimately did
was they used a bunch of
images in their stores,
all their 750 stores.
They put them in their marketing
brochures, on their
website, billboards--
you name it, in anything
they wanted to.
And they licensed these images
for sole use for four months.
Nobody else could use them
for any other purposes.
And it was a lot of fun.
It was a lot of fun because I
learned a lot about how that
world works.
And being a former project
manager, showing up and doing
contract negotiation
was a lot of fun.
Because now I was in the
driver's seat working with an
ad agency of creative people
negotiating contracts.
So that was a lot of fun.
So what they did is they
basically put them in all
stores, every little nook
and cranny where
they could find it.
And I don't know if anybody
remembers in that year a lot
of women handbags, giraffe-print
purses?
That was the campaign that
we did together.
I think the most fun part of
that negotiation is when they
came back and said, Andy, we
could really use a few more
images for our stores.
We're kind of stretching
these images a lot.
People are going to walk into
different sales areas within
the stores, and they're going
to see the same photographs.
Could we do more?
I said, yeah, sure.
Just you know what
this many took.
Take that.
You can figure out the
cost pretty quickly.
And they said, well, we kind
of ran out of money.
And I said, oh, well, being a
former budgeting guy, I can
figure this out.
So if you ran out of money,
let's go find somebody else's
budget that has money.
And they said, OK, well,
give us an idea.
And I said, you know what?
Let's throw a party.
Let's throw a party where
I can get some PR
value out of this.
So they threw a big party.
And what they did is they
basically announced to all
their Visa cardholders for
Banana Republic, if you've
made a purchase--
I think it was at least $600 in
the last 12 months, and you
live within 100 miles
of San Francisco--
we're going to send
you an invitation.
And we're going to have
a private party.
We're going to serve alcohol.
We're going to have a DJ.
We're going to put
it in our store.
And we had something like 900
people come through the doors
in 120 minutes.
And it was a lot of fun because
it just kind of
created a lot of PR for me.
And I got some additional
value out of that.
And then they said, OK, well,
can we use those images now?
I said, well, let's keep working
on this a little more.
And I said, you know
what you should do?
You should design, print,
distribute, oh, maybe 100,000
About Andy cards and put them
behind the checkout counter of
every store.
If you like these photographs,
maybe you could buy one, too.
So we drove additional sales.
We hit another different budget
within the organization
that allowed us to--
I could basically earn more
income indirectly from them
without them really having
to spend much money.
So there are all these really
creative things that
photographers can do that are
not necessarily someone
cutting you a check.
In this world right now, there's
so many people that
contact photographers that say,
oh, we'd love to use your
photographs.
We have no budget.
And I have a really nice
response to that.
It's usually something to the
effect of, thank you for your
consideration.
I appreciate that.
Boil it down, that doesn't
pay the bills.
I'd love to donate to
your organization.
But I do that through a
different process, so sorry.
And then in 2008, it was another
big part of the year,
I started a camera
bag company.
Has anybody heard of
Gura Gear before?
So I started that in 2008.
And I was really tired of
carrying around heavy, heavy,
heavy camera bags.
You can imagine, as a wildlife
photographer, I was carrying
big lenses with me.
The problem is that most
international airlines are
limited to 10, 12 kilos for
carryons, so like 22, 24,
maybe 25 pounds at the most.
And if you're carrying a 500 or
600 millimeter lens, that's
8 to 12 pounds.
That's 50% of your weight
allocation right there.
And most bags that can
carry that lens
weigh 7 to 12 pounds.
So suddenly, you're on safari
with no camera,
a bag, and a lens.
That doesn't work.
So I removed all the weight.
And here's a little product
promo shot I took in Kenya a
couple years ago.
So how does a wildlife
photographer shoot?
Here in the States, most
wildlife photography is done
handheld, on a tripod.
You walk out into a field,
and you take photographs.
Well, in Africa, much of it is
done with a Land Cruiser or a
Land Rover.
And we basically drive
out on safari.
We usually do two game
drives in a day.
And we just go see
what we can see.
But we always have some
sort of game plan.
And the game plan is we're going
to track the second we
leave camp.
We're going to track big paws.
We're looking for leopards.
We're looking for lions.
What are they doing?
Where are they going?
And in the morning, that's
my morning paper.
That's the first thing that
I read in the morning.
We're trying to figure out
what's going on, what happened
in the night, where
did everything go.
And we track.
And in this photograph, we've
got a tracker sitting on the
hood of the vehicle who's
helping us figure out where
everything's going.
And at some point, he may get
out of the vehicle, take a
rifle, and walk off for half
an hour or an hour.
And we'll go pick him
up some other area.
And he'll be self sufficient.
He's just trying to track
what's going on.
This is another vehicle
configuration without a
canopy, when it's
cooler outside.
And you can see we've got bean
bags that we set up to support
our lenses.
And it's really fairly easy.
You don't have to
do much work.
The guides and the trackers do
all the work for you-- yes?
He was asking, is there
are some sort of
clamp to the rail?
There is a clamp with a
stem and a bean bag
sitting right there.
I bring those on safari with
me for all my customers.
And anybody who likes to go
off-roading in the States has
no clue until you get into one
of these big bad boys.
These are great because
they've got big, huge
inflatable tires.
And this is in the Okavango
Delta, where the water is
often over the top
of the tires.
So we're having to drive through
through the water to
get to another area.
It's pretty common.
I kind of giggle a little bit
when I see vehicles with the
snorkels on them here
in the States.
I'm thinking, when was the last
time you forded a river?
Probably not yet.
Yeah, and then sometimes,
we just use a bean bag.
Sometimes we handhold
our lenses.
The neat thing about most of the
safaris that I run is that
you don't have to have huge
lenses to get great
photographs.
Remember, it's all about
visual storytelling.
Visual storytelling doesn't mean
you have to zoom in on
everything.
And at the end of the
presentation, I want to talk
to you about one idea of how to
visually tell a story in 10
photographs--
just some ideas on that.
And here we've got a lioness
lying on a vehicle.
We were all laughing, thinking,
oh, that guy can't
leave any time soon.
And then right when we were
chuckling, we saw
his hand stick out.
[LAUGHING]
ANDY BIGGS: OK, it's perfect
timing, isn't it?
Yeah, they were stuck there
for quite a while.
You may see a lot of wildlife
images of something like this,
where you've got an animal
filling the frame.
And you maybe don't understand
what's really going on.
Because you're not--
the photographer's
only selecting a
small area of the scene.
What's really going on is
something like this.
So here's a vehicle behind on
the other side that we sat
there and waited for him
to walk towards us.
Normally, we won't get that
close to the wildlife.
We let them get closer to us.
And we're just waiting
for him to walk off.
Here's Laurie.
So this is a typical
vehicle in Kenya.
A little bit different, where
you can stand up, as well.
I think I've got an image
of that in a minute.
You can just put your bean
bag down there and take a
photograph.
And if you make me angry, I'm
going to make you pull the
vehicle out of the mud.
This is just a photo op.
We were laughing and giggling.
I told one of my travelers,
hey, get out there
and pull the chain.
But not all photography is
done from a Land Rover.
We're often flying around
in helicopters.
And helicopters are very, very,
very efficient ways of
getting a unique angle
to wildlife.
The challenge with that is you
don't want to fly too close.
Because the closer you get with
a really loud turbine
engine, the more they get scared
or angry, and they'll
go away from you.
You don't want that.
And so what we do is we have
these helicopters in Botswana.
And we will take
the doors off.
And every now and then somebody
will ask me a
question like, Andy, what about
the air conditioning?
No problem on that
one, you've got--
anyway.
So we put two photographers on
the left and one on the right.
And we basically fly figure
eights around our subject.
And here you can see a
little bit closer in
with a fisheye lens.
We put our gear on the floor.
We put it on the side.
And we're always in contact with
the pilot, saying, hey,
check that out over here.
Let's go check that out.
And what I'm always looking
for is something that is
clear, away from
the vegetation.
Remember that most animals are
looking to either drink, eat,
sleep, fight, fornicate.
And you have to think about
that, which means most of the
time, they're going to
be in the shade.
They're going to be next to a
tree, not out in the middle of
a field, unless they're
a grazer.
So here we've got some
giraffes walking off.
Here we've got some elephants
in some shallow water.
Again, it's not about zooming in
and filling the frame with
your subject.
This is actually from a
helicopter shooting way out at
a low angle, just a gentle
sloping angle.
And here's one from a couple
months ago in November, in the
Delta, the Okavango Delta, where
we've got a small family
herd of four elephants--
mother in the front, nice
separation between all the
individuals.
And remember, we've been
talking about shape.
And shape is really important
for the photographer.
Whenever you've got shape,
it's separated from
foreground, background.
That's good, because it helps us
home in on what the subject
is all about.
If you've got a really, really
complicated background, it's
hard for the viewer to
understand what's going on.
They have to work that
much harder.
And whenever you've got a color
difference between your
subject and the background,
that's good.
That's separation.
Whenever you've got a
light difference--
black to white, a
hue difference--
those are tools that we use to
help create those shapes or
separate the shapes.
Whenever someone says, hey,
Andy, what are the tents like
in Tanzania or camping out in
the Serengeti, I just have to
show one photograph and say,
this is not a tent that you
had in Boy Scouts.
This is a proper tent.
You've got plumbing, even
though it's temporary.
So we'll set these up.
We call these Hemingway-style
camps.
But it's not roughing it.
So whenever I leave home and
go out to the Serengeti or
Botswana or wherever I go, we're
always well taken care
of so we can focus
on photography.
And sometimes we stay
in really super
swanky places like this.
Electricity--
either using solar for the camp,
and sometimes they use
backup diesel generators.
And then we'll usually eat
outdoors at night.
So I never have to worry about
accommodations, food,
anything like that.
Yes?
Yeah, so the question
is, how much editing
is done in the field?
For me, it's very different from
my travelers, my guests,
my customers.
I'd say most of my customers
download once a day, look at
their photographs,
not edit them.
Look at them.
Learn from them.
And then put what they've
learned in action the next
game drive or the next day.
I have something over 200 gigs
of compact flash cards--
I don't know, something
like that.
And I will probably download
every three to five days.
Because I'm really busy.
My day is back from a game
drive, everybody heads to
their tents, to their rooms.
And I'm basically making sure
that lunch is going to be on
time, what's going on, getting
a presentation ready for the
night, the evening time--
what are we going to do in the
afternoon game drive--
maybe working with somebody one
on one with their laptop.
So I don't get a chance to
download very often.
So I just live off the
grid for a long time.
And then hopefully I'll
back up at some point.
Sometimes, we'll have these
really cool adventures like
going to Mahale Mountains, which
is on the western part
of Tanzania, which is on Lake
Tanganyika on the western side
is Democratic Republic
of Congo.
And this is on the
Tanzania side.
It's the second largest, by
volume, freshwater lake in the
world nobody has
ever heard of.
But it's amazing.
And to go there, it takes six
hours of bush plane flights,
and having to go up and down
on a dhow, a boat.
You can see the boat on the
bottom part of this frame--
into this mountain area looking
for wild chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees are very, very
difficult to track.
Because you have to have
a lot of trackers.
And they move often.
So the trackers leave at 6
o'clock in the morning.
They go up into the forest.
And they start radioing in where
they've seen them last,
where they bed down, where
are they heading,
where are they eating.
And then hopefully when you
arrive two, three, four hours
later, and you've been
hiking, they haven't
gone away too far.
But sometimes they do.
So it might involve 6, 8, 10
hours of trekking in the day
just to find your subjects.
And then the area they say, once
you get to them, you can
only photograph them
for 60 minutes.
And then you must leave.
So it's very restrictive.
And these are very wild animals,
very difficult
photography.
For those who are into
photography and all the techie
nerdy stuff, basically, this is
with a 70 to 200 lens on a
D700 shooting at probably
ISO 3200, wide open.
It's a dark canopy.
It's a very, very, very
difficult place to photograph.
But it's also one of
the most rewarding.
This was in South Africa
few years ago.
We were watching a lioness take
out an impala in the mud.
And she obviously had
mud all over her.
This is the extreme part, the
northern part of Namibia,
along the Angola border.
It's the Himba tribe.
And even though I photograph
wildlife primarily, I love to
photograph cultures all
throughout Africa.
And these are fascinating
people, some of the last
semi-nomadic people in Africa.
And what's great about them
photographically is they still
dress traditionally.
And they cover themselves with
an ochre that's been mixed
with a butter fat.
And they coat their bodies and
also burn and smoke some
Commiphora for basically
their smell.
They smell really nice.
And it's really fascinating
to shoot them.
So on this day, we decided,
hey, let's go to the local
village, basically hut, and
let's see if they'll let us
take their photographs.
And we went there.
And they said, oh, yeah,
we'd love to do that.
And we said, OK, would
you mind walking
out on the sand dunes?
And they started laughing.
They're like, we
do that anyway.
Why would you pay
us to do that?
And they said, wait, pay.
Oh, yeah, so can you bring us
back-- we'll do it tomorrow--
but can you bring
us some tobacco,
some sugar, some maize.
So we went off and bought some
of that and brought it back.
And they just thought it was the
most hysterical thing to
walk out on the dunes, which
they do every day anyway.
And it was a fun time.
It was a fun time.
Here's a Maasai in Tanzania
a few years ago.
I find cultural photography a
little more difficult for me.
I'm used to photographing
animals, where it's a little
less of an intimate
relationship, even though I
observe and watch.
People photography is something
that I have to force
myself to do and try
harder and harder.
And I find it hard because
it's the separation of
background and separation
of subject that
always intrigues me.
So here we've got a greeting
dance that they're greeting us
when we came into the village.
And they're all encircling us.
We talked about action, where
we talked about this
adjective-driven approach
to photography.
And it doesn't mean
that I always stay
within those bounds.
Here we've got action
at a water hole.
And I'll shoot it.
I may not show it a lot.
So there's a difference
between shooting,
editing, and showing.
So I have to communicate on my
blog, on Google+, on all these
different places, what I'm
doing, who I am, what my
photography looks like.
Because I'm trying to
reach people to go
on safari with me.
And I have to think about what
they want from their safari
versus just what I want.
So I have to separate my
portfolios, the one that I
like to print and sell versus
what I want to communicate for
people to get them interested
in coming with me.
And a lot of men, specifically,
are interested
like, I want to kill.
I want to kill.
I'm like, OK.
So I have to communicate that
side of the business.
And then usually once somebody
sees it, they're like, yeah,
let's not do that again.
It's really funny.
Once you see it and you realize,
it's maybe not what
you hoped for.
But it usually involves a lot
of sitting, a lot waiting, a
lot of patience.
And this actually happened on
the safari with Aravind a few
years ago, two years ago
in the Serengeti--
we just sat by a water hole.
Again, action--
there's a little bit of implied
activity going on here
that's not maybe true.
Here we've got a hippo in the
late afternoon, yawning.
But it looks aggressive.
It looks like he's being
very, very aggressive.
This also isn't a really
large adult.
It's more of a teenager
or a young adult.
But you see all the water
splash going on.
I'm showing the aggressive
side of photography or of
African wildlife.
Here we've got an elephant.
We pulled around a corner,
and she decides she
didn't want us there.
And she just basically opened
up her eyes and took off.
We startled her.
It wasn't intentional.
But it was a photographic
moment.
I love to slow down
the shutter speed.
Now, slowing down the shutter
speed gives this implied
movement, implied
action, power--
the adjective-driven
approach, right--
this power.
And if you can slow your
shutter speed down to
something like a 60th, a 30th, a
10th, maybe even far down as
something like a fifth of a
second, it really shows a
different side of photography.
It can be very creative.
It's very difficult, very
frustrating to shoot this way.
Because you may shoot 200
or 300 photographs
and get zero keepers.
But pixels are cheap,
ie, free.
And you can just delete them.
It's OK.
But it takes a lot of
patience to shoot
slower shutter speeds.
Because you have to pan
through the shot.
You have to have the same
autofocus point on the same
spot of the subject all
the way through.
And you have to learn which
shutter speeds are appropriate
for which animals and
how fast they are.
Like something walking, you'd
really slow down their shutter
speed versus something
that's running.
I also love this kind of
interaction between species.
I'm not necessarily a
bird photographer.
But I won't shy away from
being an opportunistic
photographer, taking shots
when I can get them.
So here, we've got a Cape
buffalo, which most people
think of as a very dangerous,
aggressive--
they can be--
animal, with a bird.
It almost has this kind of yin
and yang approach to it.
This is called an oxpecker.
And it's a symbiotic
relationship, where the
oxpecker is basically cleaning
the animal of ticks.
And the animal wants it there.
But not the only animal
that likes it there.
Here's an oxpecker
on a white rhino.
So I love these kind of
relationships between animals,
if you can get them.
And it's often difficult.
Because there aren't that
many that interact.
Usually, it's predatory--
animals trying to kill
something else.
Or maybe paying attention to
those small little details
that make you laugh.
Here we've got two brothers that
are just pulling on each
other's ear.
I mean, mom was over
there eating.
And the other mom was eating.
And they just were playing
around and horsing around.
And it was about just finding
those little small moments,
those little small details that
kind of make you laugh.
Lighting and wildlife
photography and nature
photography is very important.
There are so many different
types of lighting.
We wanted to use the language
of angles of light.
Where is the light in relation
to your subject?
We also have the language of
soft, harsh, warm, cold.
And you have to think about
environments and situations
when they're going to a certain
light is going to
bring you something
that's different.
So always play to
the positives.
Here we've got a hot
air balloon--
I'm in a balloon myself--
a hot air balloon.
But we also have what looks
like fog on the ground.
Well, whenever you put light
behind anything in the air
like rain, sleet, snow, water,
vapor, dust, fog, it
illuminates.
It shows up.
And so if you throw light behind
there, it transforms
the photograph.
This is actually not fog.
This is actually the dust from
the vehicles that were chasing
the hot air balloons to make
sure that when we landed,
there was somebody to
grab the ropes.
But it's still about visual
storytelling, right?
The angle of light is
really important.
And if anybody has watched the
BBC's "Planet Earth," you'll
notice this in probably
75% of their shots.
Basically, they're doing what
I call 3/4 lighting, which
means that the light is behind
the subject, but not direct
enough to cause a lens
flare on the lens.
This helps define the shape.
Because there's an adage in
photography that light
illuminates and shadows
define.
And a shadow is necessary to
have a line or an edge.
So where are you going to put
the shadow and the edge?
Well, I like it on the
edge of the animal.
Makes sense, right?
So here we've got this nice
soft glow on the left-hand
side, or the edge,
like a rim light.
But there's still enough light
to illuminate her face.
And we have these great
processing tools now, when we
develop our photographs, where
we can pull out things from
the shadows, where in the
film world, this was
hard to pull off.
You could do it.
You just had to nail your
exposure within
a third of a stop.
We talked about harsh
light a second ago.
Play to the positives.
If it's a harsh light, just
blow out the sky.
There are a lot of photographers
out there that
are shooting portraits and
weddings that are doing this.
And they're setting the trend.
And wildlife photographers like
myself are just taking it
and running with it and
doing the same thing.
So here, we've got a back-lit
leopard in a tree.
And it's created a nice rim
light around her paws.
You can see the bottom
of her body.
And you don't really worry about
the sky because there's
nothing interesting
in the sky.
Same kind of concept here.
Actually, in the original file,
there's quite a bit of
lens flare.
I'm OK with it.
When I started this in 2002,
I used to be so picky about
everything that was
inside that frame.
And I wanted everything
to be perfect.
And now I'm just, pfft.
11 years later, I just
will shoot it.
And if it looks cool--
as long as it's conveying a
sense of space, that people
have some sort of emotional
reaction to the photograph,
then it's a successful image,
even if it has a lot of
technical faults.
If you guys read magazines like
"National Geographic,"
you'll probably notice that
there are a lot of images with
significant technical faults.
But it doesn't matter.
Because it's about visual
storytelling and conveying
what needs to be said.
And so what if something
is a little bit blurry?
It just doesn't matter as long
as the overall image works.
Again, here's another
back-lit image.
Here's a leopard in a tree.
Here's a good example.
Here's kind of the standard sun
over my shoulder, looking
at the leopard.
She looks up.
That's great.
There's really nothing
going on.
It's direct.
It's flat because there's
no shadow.
So why not drive onto the
other side and get a
photograph on that side, which
looks a lot more dramatic?
I would prefer not to have
the tree growing
right through her head.
But basically, sometimes
you have to take
what you can take.
But it's a different look.
You're able to get more of that
contrast, more of the
color, a lot more drama,
because you're
getting those shadows.
Speaking of shadows,
silhouettes, another approach
to photography, as long
as you've got the
shape worked out.
Silhouettes are all
about shape.
This is such a common scenario,
which drives most
photographers crazy--
complicated subject, complicated
background,
complicated light, complicated
everything.
It's hard to figure out what's
going on other than it looks
like you've got a lying
leopard up in a tree.
This is not processed.
This is straight out
of the camera.
But it illustrates a typical
scenario, where you're like,
oh, that's cool.
But it's really, really
hard to pull off.
Here we've got a big branch
right in front of her body, a
lot of lines.
I mean, nature is inherently
messy.
And it's our jobs as
photographers to clean it up.
And I think of that cleaning
up as usually removal.
We're using our lenses to
include or exclude things.
So I think photography is all
about excluding things as
opposed to including things.
Like a painter includes
things--
blank canvas, add stuff.
We take things out.
But this is what I'd
rather have.
I'd rather have that.
So now we have an
easier-to-figure-out subject,
because we've got the
light on her.
We've got an easier set of tree
branches that are not all
in the way.
That's what we're looking for--
not this, but that.
And it just takes patience and
spending time and waiting.
Usually a leopard hangs out in a
tree until it wants to hunt,
which is usually at night, which
means you find them in
the afternoon, they're probably
going to be there
later in the afternoon.
So we drive around and do some
other things, return back to
the same tree.
And maybe a photograph isn't
always about color.
When do you use color
versus when do you
use black and white?
We talked about shape, right?
Well, color works, but maybe
shape works, too,
for black and white.
I'm not sure which one's
better here.
They're different.
But I encourage you to take
photographs that maybe didn't
have good color, consider
it as a black and white.
I like to have very contrasty
photographs where there's a
deep black and a bright white in
every scene that helps get
an overall sense of--
drama, I think, gets
added from that.
And then I love intimacy in
wildlife photography.
And that's usually happening
between two of the same
species, like a mother
and a cub.
Here we've got a mother
and a baby here.
Or maybe we've got a
mother and a cub.
I really prefer that, because
that helps me support those
adjectives we've talked
about earlier--
hopeful, regal, uplifting.
That's what I'm really trying
to shoot for because
photography--
people who buy images are
rarely buying images of
aggressive subjects.
I think when we think African
wildlife photography, what's
the first animal people
think about?
Usually a lion or an elephant.
Well, a lion--
most the time people, I think,
want that yawn, that real big
aggressive roar.
The reality is getting that into
an economic model doesn't
really translate very much.
I don't know many companies or
people who want to buy a
print, put it on the wall
of a roaring lion.
So this helps me sell images.
Because I'm in the business of
staying in business, right?
So licensing photographs--
this is kind of what really
sells in the marketplace.
OK, let's end this discussion
in a few secs, and I'll take
some questions.
But let's end on some
storytelling ideas.
Years ago, when I got into
this business, two
professional nature
photographers
told me over a margarita.
They said, Andy, you need to
figure out whether your
storytelling style is one
photograph that sits on
somebody's wall or your wall,
above the fireplace
or above the couch.
Or are you looking for the
series of photographs?
Are you more of an editorial
photographer?
Are you looking to take 5,
10, 15, 20, 50, 100, 130
photographs--
130 is typically the number of
photographs used in a coffee
table book.
How does it come out of you?
It's natural.
And I'm like, I'm a
single shot guy.
I mean, I know that.
And that helps me go down
one path and not
try the other one.
But every now and then,
sometimes I run a safari where
someone hires me, like a CEO
who wants to bring other
executives, or maybe it's
a patriarch of a family.
And they said, Andy, we've hired
you to run this safari,
teach us some photographs.
But would you also mind
documenting our safari for us?
We would love to have
photographs of the family.
Now, I'm not a portrait
photographer.
I don't pretend to be.
But I like a challenge.
So I'll do those things.
But storytelling--
I thought, let me throw some
images together to kind of
illustrate a day in the
life of a safari.
Maybe it's seven photographs.
Maybe it's nine.
Maybe it's 10.
But usually when you start
telling stories like this on a
web page, and you're showing
them to family, they're bored
by the fourth photograph.
Because they're seeing
the same image-- oh,
look, another elephant.
Great, right?
Because they weren't there.
They want to see people that
they know and love in the
photograph.
So here we've got leaving first
thing in the morning,
driving around, slow
shutter speed.
Here we've got our tracker up
on the front of the vehicle.
Here's our guide smiling at us
through the rear-view mirror.
Oh, look, a detail shot.
Here's a photograph of one
of us with a big lens.
We go on hikes sometimes.,
and we shoot from the
ground, just walking.
OK, there's our subject.
We're shooting giraffes
off in the distance.
Oh, look, we stopped for
a tea and coffee break.
So going in for those
detail shots.
Everything about storytelling
is about glue.
How does one photograph get
glued to the next one?
And how do they all
glue together?
Oh, look, smiling,
happy faces.
That's a good thing from
a marketing standpoint.
Oh, look, we've got some
wildlife shots, great.
And then end of the day, we're
going to do some tracking.
We've got some leopard tracks
going up and down a road.
We had no idea which
way they're going.
Let's go down one direction
first and
see what we can find.
Sunset shot, we're done.
So just a quick way of thinking
about storytelling is
really trying to glue images
together that all
somehow make sense.
But if they were to stand on
their own, they're not the
photographs you're going to put
up on your wall as a big,
huge 40 by 60 print.
I mean, maybe this
one would be OK.
But maybe not that one.
They're just different
purposes.
I know a lot of people these
days who are building Blurb
books and things like that.
Well, that's a totally different
style of editing and
including photographs than doing
something like these
images earlier, like that.
This is that kind of I want
it to stand on its own.
But shooting in a series is
very, very, very different.
And then stopping the action--
love stopping the action.
Sitting at a water hole, just
shooting, shooting, shooting.
Zebras, as they come down to the
water, is exciting because
eventually they get spooked.
And about every 10, 15 minutes
it resets again, and they come
down to drink.
So four times an hour, you're
getting good photographic
opportunities.
And for me, in the way I think
of things, four times in an
hour to shoot something
rich is awesome.
Because sometimes you might
drive around for two or three
hours not finding what fits
your adjective list.
Well, thank you, guys.
Let's do some questions.
How much time do we have
for questions?
5, 10 minutes-- yeah, cool.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was wondering since
wildlife photography is
such a kind of an on-the-fly
kind of thing where you really
have to capture things in the
moment, are you consistently
using shutter priority
and autofocus?
Or how often do you go
just full manual?
ANDY BIGGS: That's a really
great question.
I'm all over the board,
depending on the scenario.
So if I'm hypersensitive to
shutter speed, which is
usually when I want to slow the
shutter speed down, I'll
switch to shutter-speed
priority.
I would say most of the time,
I'd be in aperture priority
mode because that's what's
most important for me.
In recent years with
specifically Nikon cameras,
they do a really good
job with auto ISO.
So I'll shoot in manual mode,
I'll set my shutter speed, my
f-stop, and I'll let it
choose the ISO for me.
Unfortunately, Canon hasn't
figured that out very well
yet, the exposure
compensation.
But I'm kind of all over the
board is the answer.
But I'd say 75% of the time,
I'm probably in aperture
priority mode.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And autofocus?
ANDY BIGGS: Actually,
I'm always in
continuous autofocus mode.
And for anybody who has an
SLR with a rear autofocus
capability, usually on Canons,
it says AF On--
and actually Nikons
are the same--
AF On on the back, I prefer to
use the rear autofocus button,
not the shutter speed
autofocus button.
Because I can leave it in
continuous or AI Servo mode
and take my thumb off to stop
focusing whenever I want to.
So I don't have to
switch modes.
And the reason why I use the
rear autofocus button is that
I look at it from a process
standpoint.
I'm a process guy.
Back basically when Leica
invented the first 35
millimeter camera, we
had an aperture
selection on the lens.
We had a shutter speed
on the camera.
And whatever the film speed
was, that's what it was.
And then in the '50s,
they developed
meters in the cameras.
And they said, well, where
are we going to put the
functionality for the meter?
Oh, let's put it on the
shutter button.
OK, so now we've got two
functions in one button.
In the late '80s, when autofocus
came out, hey, let's
have autofocus.
Where are we going to put
the functionality?
Hey, let's put it on
the shutter button.
So now we've got three
functions, one button.
So autofocus, metering,
and take the shot.
And that just fries my brain
thinking about that.
From a UI standpoint, it
just doesn't work.
So I prefer to shoot with
autofocus on the thumb,
because it's independent
of my forefinger.
Hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Can you say a few
words about the different
countries in which
you operate?
And the character
of each country?
ANDY BIGGS: Yeah, yeah.
So the differences between
the countries.
So let me--
I'll make a broad statement
first and say that I go to
areas where there's
a lot of wildlife.
And wildlife exists where there
are not a lot of humans.
So typically more remote
locations--
Kenya, Tanzania, Botswana,
South Africa, Namibia.
Rwanda's in there, even though
that's a very densely
populated country.
And the Virunga Mountains are
basically an island amongst a
sea of people, where the
mountain gorillas are.
I only travel to areas
that are what I
consider to be safe.
Because I'm a father and
a husband as well.
I want to come home.
So it's very important to me.
So usually, we get to places
that are remote.
We fly into a major city and
we fly out the next day.
And we get out in the
middle of nowhere.
Most of my safaris are
split between--
I'd say Kenya, Tanzania, and
Botswana, which are very, very
easy places to get to,
politically stable.
I know Kenya had some issues
a couple years ago.
But really, on the whole, these
are very, very, very
stable places.
In other words, I'm not running
trips to West Africa,
Nigeria any time soon.
So East Africa is
a broad brush.
East Africa is more wide open
savannah, where you have more
grazing herding animals,
wildebeest and zebras.
You get the wildebeest
migration, 2 million
wildebeests, 450,000 zebras--
really, really big.
Southern Africa tends
to be smaller
congregation of animals--
same species, just smaller
congregations and more
intimate experiences.
Because East Africa typically
works off of a national park
method, where you pay fees to
be in the park, as well as
other people.
And you'll see them.
Southern Africa--
South Africa, Botswana--
tend to work off of a game
reserve, private game reserve,
concession kind of a model
where a given camp has
exclusive access to an area.
And you'll see very few, if any,
vehicles within a day.
Fees are a lot higher
in Southern
Africa than East Africa.
I would say it's a fair
statement to say that most of
my safari travelers will
start off with a
Tanzania or Kenya safari.
They'll get interested and say,
this is a lot of fun.
And they'll end up doing a
Botswana safari later, because
it's a little bit more
of a commitment
in time to get there.
Financially, as well,
it's more expensive.
But the species are virtually
the same everywhere that I go.
So the question is, how did I
start the safari business and
put together the first safari?
I'm a networker.
My personality is really driven
around talking to
people and engaging
with people.
And I knew Michael Reichmann,
who owned Luminous Landscape
website, which is a nature
photography, a
very popular site.
I emailed him and said, hey,
let's put a safari together.
He said, that sounds great.
So that helped me build up a
name in the industry with
somebody that was well known.
And then it kind of
went from there.
I was very fortunate in that I
was able to follow the same
trajectory that digital
photography took at the same
time that baby boomers were
starting to retire or cutting
back on their work commitment.
So international travel
was made easier
10 or 15 years ago.
It's just gotten easier
and easier and
easier every decade.
But really, I'd say the late
'90s started getting really
easy to a lot of these
places that I go.
Digital photography
was on the rise.
I bought my first pair of
digital SLRs in 2002, the
original D30 Canon.
Paid three grand
each for them--
three autofocus points,
awesome.
And I was seeing my customers
doing the same thing.
People were getting
reinvigorated by digital
photography.
Oh, I shot film but I stop
shooting in the '80s.
Something like that was
usually the story.
Most of my travelers are either
empty nesters slash
baby boomers, or high tech, one
kid or no kids, younger
30s, late 20s into the 30s,
early 40s, kind of that
demographic, and just a high
interest in digital
photography that didn't
exist before.
It's all about networking.
So I really appreciate you
guys coming out today.
I wanted to be very mindful of
just one hour so that you can
get back to your normal
daily life here.
So thanks, guys, for
having me out here.
[APPLAUSE]